japan is facing a serious conundrum
it has sunk so much money into the
olympics
officially 15.4 billion
u.s dollars and if tokyo cancels the
games
the country stands to lose an estimated
16.5 billion
so organizers are loath to stop the
games
but citizens see a public health danger
if the event moves forward
the majority do not want it to happen
especially because most of the country
remains unvaccinated
aussie spirit the australian olympic
softball team
is the first international squad to
arrive in japan
and they're facing unprecedented
restrictions
no restaurants no sightseeing and
certainly no socializing i think that
these athletes as well
know that they have to take great
responsibility for their own behaviour
as well they're committed to do that
they're committed to not only look after
themselves but do the right thing by the
japanese population as well
and be ready for the games most people
in japan do not want the olympic games
to happen
they're questioning the sense 15 000
olympic and paralympic athletes
from more than 200 countries traveling
to japan
at a time when serious covert 19 cases
have recently hit new
highs the nation's slow vaccination
rollout
isn't helping either
japan has been working hard to roll
vaccines out
but demand did not match with supply and
that was from the very start
japanese olympic athletes are now being
offered
jabs but only about two and a half
percent of japan's population
has been fully vaccinated so far
despite all this the organizers are
standing firm
sports events are held all over the
world
and as i've said there are no examples
of clusters of the infection spreading
therefore we believe we don't need to
think about cancelling now
the arrival of australia's softball team
is
a huge show of confidence in the
beleaguered event
all team members tested negative after
landing
but the question remains will this be
enough
to restore the confidence of the
japanese public in the games
that's it for today we'll leave you with
some more pictures of japan's olympic
torch relay running
through the fukui prefecture thanks for
watching see you tomorrow
[Music]
[Music]
you